la france veut aider le nouveau
souverain marocain jacques chirac l'a
rappelé ce soir au cours d'un grand
dîner d'honneur au palais de l'elysée
c'est la première visite à l'étranger
pour le roi mohamed6 visite suivie par
christian malheur un jeune monarque que
mohamed 6 un président de la république
jacques chirac qui cultive une solide
amitié deux pays la france et le maroc
qui entretiennent des relations très
privilégiées
devant déboucher sur un véritable
partenariat économique et politique
voilà en gros les hospices sous
lesquelles se déroule la visite du
souverain chérifien en france au cours
de ses entretiens avec jacques chirac -
médecis qui est soucieux de justice
sociale a longuement développé son
projet de société qui vise à corriger
les déséquilibres profonds qui ont
existé jusqu'à lors et qui s'inscrit
résolument dans une logique occidentale
et moderniste même si depuis trois
semaines sont payés est officiellement
associés à la communauté européenne
le souverain marocain aimerait bien
qu'il en devienne un membre permanent
cela dit soyons honnêtes l'europe a déjà
du mal à se faire à 15
on a du mal à imaginer son élargissement
au maroc alors qu'il ya déjà douze
autres pays parmi lesquels la turquie
qui frappe depuis longtemps à sa porte
pourtant ce soir au cours du dîner
officiel mohamed 6 a à nouveau frappé à
la porte de l'europe
le moment est peut-être aussi venu de
donner à l'agenda européen dans notre
région des tonalités différentes des
tonalités qui laisserait espérer au
maroc comme à d'autres pays du sud de la
méditerranée qu'il pourrait prétendre un
partenariat qui serait à la fois plus et
mieux que l'association revu et corrigé
à laquelle nous sommes nous nous sommes
attelés et peut-être où quelque temps
encore un peu moins que l'adhésion que
nous dit pourtant la raison la
géographie et la réalité au quotidien de
la vie économique sociale et culturelle
dans nos pays
les autorités françaises sont convaincus
que mohamed 6 réussir à ses réformes
économiques et politiques pour mieux
faire régresser l'intégrisme islamique
qui gangrène l'ensemble du maghreb
lionel jospin et jacques chirac
considère que dans la perspective de ce
qu'ils appellent la construction d'un
grand boulevard euro méditerranéen
le maroc est indéniablement l'allié le
plus solide le plus fiable de la france
au sein du maghreb par rapport à
l'algérie avec laquelle nous
entretenons des relations en dents de
scie et par rapport à la tunisie dont le
régime est jugée encore trop répressif